[Music]
here's all the cute videos from the kids
party you bunnelby and North get to grow
up together that must be really special
for you in Courtney yeah and now the
three little girls are gonna grow up
together shy and stormy are just two
weeks apart and then true is just a few
months behind so that's really exciting
and Chris told us that Chloe's gonna
come back to LA soon with true and it's
she gonna get to meet all the families
yeah how excited me and Kylie and Khloe
are planning like one of those kids
photo shoots just like a silly shoot
that we can have all the girls co-star
me and Chicago have so many pictures
together so we can't wait for true to
join the crew congratulations once again
now that you have it in your hand it's
like it's all real for you yeah it
really is it's really cool and I just
kind of winged it there was so much more
I wanted to say and I'm like looking at
my sisters in the audience and I just
forgot it all the rest of us here
tonight for you Kendall and Courtney and
my friend Stephanie so your mom didn't
read it you know what she felt really
guilty and was having FOMO but I said
mom you have so many meetings there's a
lot you have to get done so do that I
have most important two sisters and you
know it's fine it kind of didn't get to
make it either no you know he's working
on another album and they needed someone
to watch the kids to be honest where
daddy there yes
[Music]